revisiter le corpus nous sommes à la
croisée des chemins
est-ce qu'on peut organiser au niveau du
terrain le dialogue social
agnès verdier molinié et vous disiez oui
il peut y avoir des accords d'entreprise
avec la réserve que vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure de la taille des entreprises
mais il faudra de toute façon passer par
la loi et je vous avais cette
proposition à nous faire pour qu'on
évite de se prendre le mur et qu'on
essaie de sauter au dessus du mur oui
bon tout beaucoup de choses ont déjà été
dites et je crois que ce qui est
important de souligner c'est que on ne
fera pas l'économie du courage politique
c'est à dire qu'à un moment il faudra
affronter les problèmes qui sont dans
notre code du travail qu'on a largement
évoqué avec ses 3500 pages et est
aujourd'hui ce qu'on entend c'est plutôt
finalement on va mettre un peu tout ça
sous le tapis et on va faire des accords
d'entreprise mon changera rien dans la
loi
et ça c'est pas possible c'est pas
possible parce que finalement on pourra
pas faire que des dérogations sans
affronter les vrais problèmes qui sont
absolument majeur alors je vais prendre
7 points
je pense qu'il faut parler un petit peu
de ce qui concrètement et là on parle
finalement d'emploi qui concrètement
empêche nos entreprises de créer de
l'emploi et qui donc nous plonge mois
après mois encore plus fort dans le dans
le chômage et c'est ça le le sujet de
bazin l'idée c'est pas refaire le code
du travail parce que tout d'un coup ce
serait une envie subite des français et
de leurs représentants c'est avant tout
répondre à l'urgence que nous vivons par
rapport à cette augmentation perpétuelle
du chômage alors sur par exemple les
accords de maintien dans l'emploi qui
datent de l'ani de janvier 2013 nous dès
que ça a été signé entre les partenaires
sociaux et après transposée dans la loi
on a dit attention on veut flexibiliser
on veut permettre de soi baisser le
temps de travail baisser les
rémunérations soit augmenter le temps de
travail augmenter
et avoir des rémunérations stable mais
en réalité on ne l'autorisent cas des
entreprises qui sont dans des
difficultés extrêmes et pour une durée
limitée
donc là on dit non il faut pouvoir
absolument dérogé à sa et que chaque
entreprise qui le souhaitent et et au
sein de laquelle et les salariés sont
d'accord puisse signer un accord de
maintien dans l'emploi
quelle que soit sa situation voilà ça
c'est peut-être ça vous paraît peut-être
basique mais aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
possible il ya très peu d'accords de
maintien dans l'emploi finalement qui
ont été signés et il faut quasiment
attendre que les entreprises soient en
faillite pour qu'elle puisse en avoir la
possibilité aujourd'hui sur la question
des 35 heures on va pas pouvoir réussir
à augmenter vraisemblablement de manière
importante le temps de travail sans
supprimer cette notion des tentes des 35
heures dans le code du travail ce n'est
pas possible donc dire que on permettra
aux entreprises de déroger par accord
d'entreprise sans toucher à la loi
là encore c'est c'est pas une
possibilité qui nous est offerte
donc là il faut prendre une décision il
ya un maximum qui est européen ces sont
les 48 heures entre les 35 et les 48 il
va falloir trouver un nombre d'heures ou
alors dire dans l'ès les 48 heures et
puis chacun s'organise dans son
entreprise mais ça c'est c'est un choc
tectoniques pour notre pays c'est à dire
de vous passer de 35 à l'idée d'avoir un
maximum de 48 et ensuite des accords au
niveau du terrain alors ça il ya
beaucoup de ya beaucoup de français qui
dans leur for intérieur et d'autres
d'entrepreneurs et de créateurs qui le
souhaitent
après c'est une décision qu'il faut
prendre
je crois que ça demande aussi de
regarder la question du déclenchement
des heures supplémentaires c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui vous pouvez choisir au
niveau des branches d'avoir des
majorations pour heures supplémentaires
qui sont seulement de 10% mais néanmoins
vous êtes toujours soit sur 25 soit sur
10 vous pourriez très bien choisir - là
aussi il ya un problème de statistiques
souvent on sait pas combien de personnes
travaillent aujourd'hui en france avec
des majorations d'heures supplémentaires
à seulement 10%
c'est très compliqué d'avoir des
informations même quand vous nous
contactez les partenaires sociaux même
les mieux informés en réalité il n'ya
aucune aucune information concrète là
dessus donc là ça demande aussi
d'accepter d'avoir un contingent
d'heures supplémentaires bien supérieur
à ce qu'on a aujourd'hui sa demande donc
là encore d'être dans la loi dans la
souplesse pour que derrière au niveau de
l'entreprise on puisse vraiment passé
des accords qui correspondent aux
besoins
ça demande aussi que sur l'annualisation
du temps de travail on soit beaucoup
plus souple qu'aujourd'hui les allemands
sur l'annualisation du temps de travail
ils ont beaucoup plus de souplesse que
nous on a fait toute une comparaison à
la fondation ifrap entre les deux
systèmes
on peut gagner énormément en souplesse
là dessus parce que l'annualisation du
temps de travail aujourd'hui en france
elle se fait à l'intérieur des 35 heures
donc on reste dans le contingent annuel
et ont peu bougé
sur une semaine le temps de travail mais
néanmoins sur l'année on reste contraint
donc là ça ça ne résout rien sur la
question du smic qui est aussi une
question là encore un beau totem en
france évidemment on peut penser
passé par du zéro charge totale au
niveau du smic
aujourd'hui il reste un petit peu de
cotisations entre 12 et 14%
néanmoins je pense que ça suffirait pas
ça suffirait pas parce que finalement
nos partenaires européens est totalement
les allemands et les britanniques ont
choisi d des méthodes beaucoup plus
disons avant gardiste on est sur des
mini jobs des jobs zéro heure alors ça
choque en france quand on dit le modèle
allemand c'est scandaleux vous sortez
cet exemple mais finalement il
fonctionne avec des mini jobs
oui il ya des pays aussi qu'ils ont le
smic jeunes les pays bas quand vous
regardez les taux de chômage des jeunes
dans pas mal de pays qui ont le smic
jeunes vous voyez que les taux de
chômage des jeunes il est inférieur à
celui qu'on a en france
donc je crois que là-dessus il faut être
beaucoup plus pragmatique permettre de
déroger au smic permettre que pour des
demandeurs d'emploi de très longue durée
on est l'équivalent des mini jobs à
l'allemande pourquoi pas parce qu'il
vaut mieux avoir un pied dans l'emploi
même avec une petite rémunération et
avec un filet social à côté c'est ce
qu'on oublie souvent de dire plutôt que
de dire à quelqu'un vous êtes au rsa
mais c'est même pas la peine de venir à
pôle emploi parce que toute façon il y
aura pas de job pour vous voilà donc on
est un peu hypocrite en france parce
qu'on préfère parquet les gens dans du
rsa socle et avoir beaucoup de jeunes en
stage pas très bien rémunéré
plutôt que d'assumer des dispositifs de
type mini jobs ou de type semi jeunes je
pense que là dessus un moment il faut
expliquer aux français que c'est
l'emploi qui prime que c'est la plus
grande des inégalités c'est de pas avoir
d'emploi c'est pas de d'augmenter en
permanence la dépense sociale pour
essayer de de faire baisser les
inégalités tout en empêchant ceux qui
peuvent investir de le faire et là
dessus
je crois qu'on pourra imaginer des
dérogations par accord de branche sur le
smic jeunes le smic territoriales
imaginez cette possibilité des mini jobs
pour ceux qui sont demandeurs d'emploi
depuis de longue durée et je pense pas
que ce soit quelque chose de totalement
tabou pour les français c'est tabou pour
nos pour ceux qui sont en permanence sur
les radios sur les télés sur ces
questions mais pas vraisemblablement pas
pour ceux qui aujourd'hui aimerait bien
avoir quelques heures de travail ensuite
la question du cdd aujourd'hui en france
pour le cd d embaucher quelqu'un en cdd
vous êtes obligés que ce soit quelque
chose de temporaire au remplacement
d'une personne qui est partie en congé
maternité est hélas il faudrait
assouplir beaucoup plus là aussi c'est
dans la loi qu'il faudra que ça passe
permettre d'embaucher en cdd de manière
beaucoup moins restrictive
alors c'est déjà un peu ce que le
gouvernement actuel avait annoncé en
disant qu'on pourrait renouveler plus
deux fois le cdd mais ils ont contraint
sa un nombre de mois qui est qui est un
peu ridicule par rapport à l'enjeu
moi je pose la question pourquoi est ce
que dans le statut public fin c'est pas
le statut public mais les contractuels
de droit public peuvent être embauchés
sur 36 mois renouvelable une fois donc
c'est à dire six en six ans de cdd
souvent d'ailleurs pas sur des postes
qui sont temporaires 1
au demeurant et pourquoi est ce qu'on
refuse ça au secteur privé voilà j'ai
jamais compris pourquoi la ja il ya une
inégalité patente mais bon peut-être
c'est pas une inégalité primordial et et
qui est dans le viseur
mais il ya des choses à faire là dessus
et aujourd'hui ça reste quand même
extrêmement corsetée donc
sortir ce cdd du carcan des besoins
temporaires permettre une durée plus
importante
ça ça serait quelque chose de
vraisemblablement pourvoyeur d'emplois
la question de la cause réelle et
sérieuse du licenciement vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure qui est en fait
celle du pouvoir du juge et de la
chambre sociale
là c'est un sujet que nous abordons à la
fondation ifrap depuis des années et des
années et des années
parce que la peur de l'embauché elle est
là réside
absolument dans ce sujet alors
évidemment qu'on va pas déroger aux
accords de l'oit est évidemment qu'on va
pas remettre en question nos nos
engagements internationaux mais dans la
rédaction de la loi il y a des
possibilités
on n'est pas obligé d'être absolument
les plus sectaires de la lecture de nos
grands engagements internationaux
donc là dessus nous avons rédigé
plusieurs plusieurs moutures potentiel
mais c'est l'entrepreneur qui doit
prévoir sa cause réelle et sérieuse et
le juge qui doit vérifier que cette
cause réelle et sérieuse existe bel et
bien et nous proposons aussi de
supprimer la référence aux difficultés
économiques
c'est à dire qu' il ne faudrait pas
qu'on soit obligé d'être dans des
entreprises là encore ça rappelle un peu
le sujet des désaccords de maintien dans
l'emploi avoir des entreprises qui sont
quasiment au bord de la faillite pour
pouvoir être autorisée à licencier parce
que concrètement c'est ça aujourd'hui
donc là il y à cette question qui est
fondamentale de permettre que quand il
ya une chute du carnet de commandes une
réorganisation bah oui ça puisse être
une cause réelle et sérieuse
alors c'est choquant mais c'est aussi la
question de préserver notre tissu
entrepreneurial et
une entreprise vous le savez mon voisin
de gauche le sait beaucoup d'entre vous
sûrement monter des entreprises en ont
vendu en ont fermé une entreprise sa vie
une entreprise ça peut commencer avec la
production de tissus et finir
producteurs de pots de yaourt et et
entre temps avoir des évolutions
incroyable sur un siècle sur sur plus
d'un siècle et c'est là le génie de ses
dirigeants de ces repreneurs de
l'adapter au contexte économique à la
fois français mais surtout
internationale et pour que ça bouge pour
que s'avivent une entreprise mais il
faut qu'elles puissent bah oui licenciés
mais licencié pour pouvoir aussi
embauché et ça les danois par exemple
ont compris depuis très longtemps
ils peuvent licencier plus facilement
ils embauchent aussi plus facilement
après la question des reclassements en
cas de licenciement économique
là encore on est sûr de la rigidité
total des obligations qui sont beaucoup
trop lourdes et parfois même
l'obligation de proposer des emplois à
des personnes qui n'ont pas du tout les
qualifications ddd des branches ou
entreprises qui restent en place et qui
mène dans des situations ubuesques qu'on
a souvent évoqué à la fondation ifrap et
on avait l'exemple d'une station service
qui était fermée parce que cause de
passage du tramway une personne qui
était pompiste et alors on lui disait
mais il faut leur classe et ans
mécanicien mais alors peut former un
mécanicien sam et 15 ans et donc cédé en
permanence ce sont des sujets comme
celui là les obligations de reclassement
elles sont trop rigides
là aussi il faudra passer par la loi
pour flexibiliser tout ça la question
des instances représentatives du
personnel je pense qu'on a on y
reviendra tout à l'heure je soulignais
dans mon livre qu'entre le début des
années 80 et est aujourd'hui on est
passé d'à peu près 200 articles sur le
sujet à 1183 article donc là on a bien
bien encadré le sujet est là clairement
ce qui a été fait sur les cee les chsct
ces derniers mois
c'est pas du tout suffisant va falloir
aller beaucoup plus loin
nous on avait proposé à la fondation
ifrap que toutes les obligations et vous
le soulignez tout à l'heure qui arrive
au seuil de 50 soit repoussé au seuil de
250 et on nous a dit c'est scandaleux et
c'est d'ailleurs j'ai eu ce débat avec
l'agglo jean claude mailly plusieurs
fois sur le fait que non non les seuils
sociaux
n'empêche pas du tout la création
d'emplois en france bizarrement nous ne
rencontrons que des entrepreneurs et il
y en a plusieurs témoignages dans mon
livre on en a publié aussi beaucoup ali
frappe d'entrepreneurs qui disent moi je
réduis le nombre de de mes salariés
parce que je veux repasser au seuil
inférieur donc ça ce sont des
témoignages de terrain
c'est embêtant oui c'est vrai on n'a pas
envie de les regarder quand on est du
côté de la défense des seuils et de
leurs de leurs obligations
mes mails me insee avait souligné que le
passage de seuils empêcher la croissance
des entreprises
quand nous on l'a chiffrée en emplois
perdus par an évidemment ça a été une
autre histoire
mais c'est peut-être 70000 à cent mille
emplois qui sont pas créés tous les ans
à cause de la rigidité des seuils et là
c'est quand même dommage dans une grand
pays où il ya 3,5 millions de demandeurs
d'emploi qui ont zéro activités de se
priver de ces emplois potentiels
après juste une question par rapport à
la question du monopole syndical et à la
question de du blocage potentiel des
accords d'entreprise une fois qu'on aura
fait tout ça une fois que déjà on aura
réussi à alléger sur ses 7 points pour
permettre ensuite que les accords
d'entreprise soit plus flexible soit
plus adapté aux entreprises
il ya une vraie question qui va aller
signer quel syndicat parce
qu'aujourd'hui il représente très peu
vous l'avez dit il représente 5 % des
salariés du privé
ils sont plus focalisés sur la défense
du statut de la fonction publique sur la
question du code du travail d'ailleurs
au demeurant à toutes les études que
nous avons faites à la fondation ifrap
nous montre que beaucoup de
des grands décideurs des centrales
syndicales sont issus des entreprises
publiques et des administrations donc
pas forcément dans l'idée d'assouplir le
code du travail parce qu'une fois qu'on
aura assoupli le code du travail
une fois qu'on aura permis des accords
plus flexible au niveau des entreprises
se posera aussi la question du statut
public et ça on ne pourra pas en faire
l'économie non plus parce qu'on ne peut
pas dire aux français qui travaillent
dans le privé
soyez hyper flexible accepter des
modifications acceptées que de changer
plusieurs fois de job de vous former de
vous de changer d'orientation et de
l'autre côté dire on ne touche
absolument pas au sanctuaire du statut
public et ça il faut pas l'oublier ça
fait partie du débat ça fait partie du
dossier et donc sur la question du
désaccord d'entreprise
il faut permettre que les référendums à
majorité permettent de faire passer les
accords voilà et on le voit sur le cas
de smart
les salariés sont d'accord à plus de 50%
et les syndicats vont réussir à bloquer
donc sinon si on continue à rester un
peu dans une idée béni-oui-oui du
dialogue social eh bien on va dire ben
oui on va faire les accords avec eux
dans le cadre du monopole syndical et
puis ce seront les salariés qui
représentent 50% des votants je souligne
votants avec trois gros tir et rouge
parce que si vous voulez votants ne veut
pas dire salariés et puis derrière on
aura aucune flexibilité aucun accord qui
passera même après avoir changé dans la
loi tout ce que j'ai listé précédemment
donc là aussi il va falloir faire faire
preuve d'inventivité et ne pas retomber
dans les pièges dans lesquels le
législateur est trop souvent tombées ces
dernières années parce que finalement on
l'a tous souligné on n'a fait que
compliquer complexifier ces dernières
années on a créé malgré toutes les
bonnes volontés quasiment aucune
flexibilité
donc ce mot de flexibilité on en veut
parce que on veut moins de chômage mais
il va falloir qu'elle soit réelle
et pas simplement dans les discours
merci beaucoup